sie wollen auf und davon
familie tobler aus dem thurgau sucht das
große abenteuer in australien rallye und
hansjörg eger aus dem aargau bauern in
thailand eine seniorenresidenz familie
tänzer aus dem kanton bern träumt von
einem besseren leben und wagte neuanfang
in florida wiedersehen mit hermann
schönbächler
der bieler förster und seine familie und
das glück tief im kanadischen wald
gefunden
[Musik]
rolf dobler und sein sohn kevin waren
vorausgereist um in australien das
nötigste zu organisieren
bevor der rest der familie eintrifft
heute kommen mutter emma sohn dylan und
baby jennifer endlich nach also ich bin
vor allem nervös und spanien schwere
berliner mit der liniennummer ob sie pro
jahr lädt die ganz dem thema schon etwas
wacklig vans stieg das wochendende koala
zum thema aufhalten
das sieht einfach an
in der letzten folge wohnten rolle von
kevin tobler auf dem campingplatz
sie fanden ein tolles haus das sie
unbedingt mieten wollten
doch sie warteten vergeblich auf die
zusage des besitzers
[Musik]
in kanada arbeitete familie schönbächler
mit schwerem gerät an ihrer ultimativen
lebensqualität beim bau des auto
unterstands halfen alle mit dennis und
tänzer gegen die florida auf haussuche
nach endlosen tagen des wartens bekamen
sie den zuschlag für ihr traumhaus
lenny und hansjörg eger erlebten in
thailand einen emotionalen empfang
gleich am ersten morgen besuchten sie
die baustelle ihrer seniorenresidenz
[Musik]
rolf von kevin tobler verbrachten drei
wochen allein in australien so lange war
die familie noch nicht getrennt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
mutter immer sondieren und baby jennifer
haben 20 stunden reise hinter sich
rolf tobias mutter rosa ist auch
mitgereist sie macht ferien in
australien und wie sehen wo ihr sohn
künftig lebt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
förster hermann schönbächler erfüllt
buben träume der wie sein sohn harry im
kanadischen wald auf weg braucht keinen
spitz und bagger im sandkasten
[Musik]
htc schülerin wir müssen wieder vor
gericht wollen ihm genau gesagt hat es
das vor fantasie oder gerade sagen gut
dass frau bobadilla dass es endlich
sie musste einfach klappen haben eine
große burg die maschinen realisieren
[Musik]
im land der großen autos und noch
größeren träume ist familie tänzer
unterwegs zu ihrem neuen zuhause
[Musik]
autohändler kleid dancer hat als erstes
einen standesgemäßen familienwagen mit
doppel bereifung gekauft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in den letzten monaten waren dennis und
clyde denzer zweimal allein durch
florida gereist auf der suche nach einem
neuen zuhause
sie erlebten viele enttäuschungen und
mussten hart kämpfen bis sie endlich die
zusage für ihr traumhaus bekam die
töchter frank und larissa sie an das
neue zuhause zum ersten mal auch um
panzer betritt neuland
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja eigentlich ist und freue mich ganz
komisch
[Musik]
in thailand haben lange und hansjörg
eger ungebetene gäste auf ihrer
baustelle
ich werd ich habe einige frühere tory
geschlossen um die kritik an wenn wenn
man die offerte von beton kießler der
uni hagen syrien becker und der grünen
muss heute ist niemand darum schaffe und
der co es heißt der looping pisten unter
der horten minuten fertig tawakoli mir
kommen oder aber jetzt kann sie auch so
hotelbesuch es gibt den gibt's immer
dabei
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
rolf und erwin tobler wollten ihre
familie mit einem bezugsbereit ein haus
in australien begrüßen
das hat nicht geklappt ihre erste
adresse ist der campingplatz
ich glaube morgen den zentren oder egal
wo oder um der brücke hauptsache sie mal
die zähne und format wieder
[Musik]
in australien ist winter das leben in
der neuen heimat beginnt mit einer
kalten macht vielleicht wie man halt
wieder zwei museen auf der lage fühle
mich unwohl und ich bin glücklich
einfach ich bin da war für mich ist okay
so ist ganz ganz schwiegermutter rosa
tobler hat sich das neue heim der
familie anders vorgestellt
also dolphin sicher
[Musik]
us
vorbei mit einem gepressten
in kanada vermessen christina und
hermann schönbächler
gerade das dach des geplanten auto
unterstands als wissen aus der schweiz
eintrifft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hermann schönbächler ehemaliger
arbeitskollege partynacht mit freunden
ferien in kanada
vielmehr ist hier wohl aber etwas kann
wir prompte weil die dachgleiche
zerbricht oder die ganz eigene schweizer
zeigen dass man in nordeuropa bis zum
labor eventuell vielleicht sogar besser
wenn man aber eine gleiche idee etwas
die matif lebensqualität ist erinnern wo
jetzt news
[Gelächter]
die vier freunde waren von den
abenteuergeschichten des spieler
försters beeindruckt das wollten sie
sich mit eigenen augen ansehen
hermann schönbächler zeigt ihnen seien
neun hektar großes grundstück dieses
paradies kaufte der förster vor zwei
jahren für gerade einmal 250.000 franken
mit beratungs häufigsten oder wenig wenn
ich jedes jahr die zehn neuen wir
betrieb sich für die eu fordert aus holz
vor dem grund nahmen 12 315 600 autos
der hersteller
der eu-kritische
[Musik]
ein gewaltiges gewitter zieht auf und
ausgerechnet jetzt sind frank und
larissa zum ersten mal allein zu hause
die mädchen wissen noch nicht so recht
was sie von der schönen neuen welt
halten sollen
[Musik]
also denkt er gerne und sollte sie jetzt
hier und da es war kleid dance hat er
die nase voll hatte vom schweizer
alltagstrott und nach florida auswandern
wollte seine frau denise hat er nie
vorgehabt auszuwandern
doch sie unterstützt er seine pläne weil
sie spürte wie sehr ihr mann einen
neustart im leben brauchte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nicht nur besteck und geschirr fehlen in
florida fangen die dancers noch einmal
ganz von vorne an
besonders für mutter durch seine
belastung
[Musik]
wir haben sohnes und wenn ja was bringen
die haben es häufig vor farfus den bau
einer seniorenresidenz in thailand hat
hansi ob jäger mit schweizerischer
gründlichkeit geplant nur die
klimatischen besonderheiten seiner neuen
heimat die hat er nicht bedacht
zwanzigster my hand weil auf tour wir
haben dort eigentlich glaubte dreißigste
wir sind ganz leer stehende noch als
rabatt ist einfach nur kinder müssen
lernen an euro pro meter war sie schon
jetzt mein sumpf dafür haben in europa
für gestrichen und planiert die
verbindungsstraße dahinter condition
ruhm der heide der schule fertig sie da
war dem ruf fenster hier haben natürlich
die griechen eben auch alle fragen rund
um einen künstlichen see bauen landi und
hansjörg eger 13 romanus diese 4000
franken im monat ein rentner aus
deutschland und aus der schweiz
vermieden werden dass elektrische stehen
der hormon ist eine haupt- als auch
ruhig machen oder
da sich cottbus masse das auto weder
schweiz hat also dass man sein handy und
ihr abstand sind 25 zentimeter abbau der
hand auf der platte haben jetzt mehr ist
einfach quatsch oder zahl und der musik
bezeichnen sich als verdoppeln und 300
weil für den teich da nicht so wichtig
da muss einfach weiter
wir sollten so lang fertig sind drei
wochen in der hand der erste gast wo da
hat weil er nichts und ja das war maxi
der arge nix da hätte ich einfach total
strich technik macht
[Musik]
nach tagen im engen zählt hat rolf
dobler eine überraschung für seine
familie
sie weiß nicht dass er den zuschlag nun
doch noch bekommen hat für jenes haus
das game und sohn kevin bei der ersten
besichtigung so gut gefallen hatte unter
einem vorwand lockte rolf dobler die
familie in ihr neues zuhause noch an sie
nichts
[Musik]
da ist stube alten dame die nächsten
sechs monate sehen
ich freue mich wahnsinnig
ich denke ein paar jahren ist egal ist
die vorschläge sehr gut ich größe welche
vorher kam
[Musik]
und so gibt es am abend auf dem
campingplatz nicht nur den ersten
geburtstag von baby jennifer zu feiern
[Musik]
wir haben jenny verwirrt sich dereinst
nicht einmal mehr daran erinnern in der
schweiz gelebt zu haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
volontär jona
[Musik]
was das ist hermann schönbächler
verwöhnt seinen besuch aus der schweiz
mit den kulinarischen reizen kann das
nicht gekonnt papa uhren aber sicher
hier ziehe ich die kleine sämtliche
karten war der spitze natürlich hoffe
dass die 45 kilo
das stück kommt dass lebensqualität
veens stück kostet 6 frank 86 $ 8 samt
gott
jedoch hat die wird doch schwitzen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
november kurz zusammen spielen
so sehr sie die abgeschiedenheit und
ruhe im kanadischen wald schätzen
christine und hermann schönbächler
freuen sich über besuch in ihrem kleinen
paradies das genial finde das absolut
genial dass es oft nicht so massive
audio video just reviews kennen oder die
irgendwie in colorado springs george
prince rupert oma fahrer als die
torreichste partie genügte beherbergen
und das so wie es aussieht
[Musik]
cloud dancer hat nicht nur den frust in
der schweiz zurück gelassen
auch fast der ganze haushalt der familie
die in der schweiz interessiert sich die
frage jetzt natürlich nicht
halle weil die frage ist ob dies eine
riesige schlank buch sony war schon
immer ein vertrag ist das nicht lange
das ist so cool und da meine ich das mal
vorstellen
ok
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hans jäger überwacht wie jeden tag die
bauarbeiten in den letzten wochen hatten
schwere regenfälle den bau der
seniorenresidenz verzögert jetzt wie der
aargauer vorwärts machen
die ersten mieter sind schon ungeduldig
[Musik]
sagte glock
da machte und wenn ich sage dass ich
nicht machen
wenn das geschieht oder per schicker
blödsinn da hat der gästebetreuer geburt
und die zeit ist echt schön machen aber
wenn ich noch hinters tor um tor für
uhrwerke und sehe dass das das dass die
plötzlich sozialvertrag maxim reagiert
auch darum zu sehen ob da blieb nicht so
ich stell dir vor du hast mir mache ja
doppelt see und stellen ihr perry trug
unser unternehmerischer ein klares guten
soße den hab ich mich nicht gross
grösser als chef
[Musik]
für immer und rolf dobler lief in der
schweiz alles wie geschmiert
und das fanden sie ziemlich langweilig
darum sind sie ausgewandert
das abenteuer australien soll ihr leben
wieder spannend machen
vater rolf l nicht mehr nur an die
arbeit denken mit der jobsuche lässt er
sich viel zeit
die familie lebt zurzeit noch von
erspart
früher hat es sein bodenleger geschäft
stets priorität jetzt soll die familie
an erster stelle stehen
spannende events lohnt sich sehr viele
zahlen
märz
[Musik]
denk mir wird noch mehr teilnehmer sein
mit geben und ich denke
jetzt wird noch intensiver und mehr
hoffe dass krieg dauert ihnen
zusammenleben 6 eingeordnet in dem
moment ein car collector und gehofft
dass sie
ja dass sie merken was
das eigentliche zu hohe mieten an
[Musik]
dennis tänzer kann das neue leben noch
nicht so genießen wie ihr mann sie sieht
im abenteuer florida erst einmal viel
arbeit bis alles eingerichtet ist
[Musik]
unbedingt
ohne verstaubt war es nie hat viel
gebucht vermittlers riese gegen cloud
dancer sucht in amerika die große
freiheit und zudem über teilt ein großer
hochdruckreiniger
[Musik]
die love play off stand 1 2
[Applaus]
die box enthält nur das ist gelogen
absolut schön im grund genau mit eine
bescheidene sachen wo man hierher deinen
segen der eu wo zwei vorgesetzte man im
grund glaube matthée sagen
sichtlich gerührt sie das ist schon das
ist schon zeitig gefreut machen
[Musik]
in thailand kommt die erste rentnerin an
die baslerin charlie becker wird einen
der 13 wohnungsmieten allee und hansjörg
eger kennen sie bereits aus der spree
gemacht
der anschlag war meine acht wochen
obwohl ihr ungarn noch nicht
bezugsbereit ist wurde die partnerin
nicht mehr länger warten
da geht stube jetzt merkte ein trio sax
ja aber jetzt erstaunt geduld haben
[Musik]
ja aber ich gehe da raus und planerische
petit oder aber kleine stier wowereit
damit um und sie wird hier sind wurde
das macht die schweizer rentnerin muss
im hotel wohnen bisher bungalow fertig
ist und das kann dauern
denn so geht es in einer woche weiter
die seniorenresidenz versinkt einmal
mehr im regen
aber es scheint als könne nicht einmal
mehr bruder helfen
frauen 1
in florida bei familie tänzer läuft es
gar nicht rund doch wenigstens
funktioniert der hochdruckreiniger
in kanada beweist hermann schönbächler
dass das geld im paradies nicht auf
bäumen sondern im moos wächst und in
australien erkundet familie tobler ihre
neue heimat die thurgauer reisen mit dem
geländewagen durchs outback
[Musik]
si
ruft es
wie will das
münster
[Musik]